okay so you're Ryan Reynolds that don't
improve me match and I want you to tell
him how you think he stole your thunder
didn't steal it Brad Pitt's revealing
how he really feels about Shania Twain
replacing his name in her song that
don't impress me much okay so you're
Brad Pitt for the singer's fellow
Canadian Ryan Reynolds and now that's
kind of amazing but who really impressed
his Queen Shania he recently joked that
Ryan Reynolds doesn't impress you
historically Brad Pitt has not impressed
you who does impress Shania Twain this
is myself I mean you know I mean he's
like
you know well it all began when Shania
performed the 1997 hit at the People's
Choice Awards in December where she
pulled the little lyric Switcheroo you
know from Brad okay so you're Brad Pitt
that don't impress me much
to Ryan okay so you're right man
yeah Ryan's face Priceless fast forward
to January and Brad's reaction to it
made its way to tick tock while
promoting his new movie Babylon and I
want you to tell him how you think he's
so your founder didn't steal I think
it's I think we can share the welfare
yeah yeah Ryan's Good Egg too he he he
deserves some love
Brad's all for it he goes even as far to
suggest who else Shania should call out
next next time she ought to sing it to
Austin Butler maybe Leo in between and
Austin Butler yep all the love to his
Once Upon a Time and Hollywood co-stars
and Pals Leonardo Dicaprio and Austin
Butler there's always going to be
something I have not done creatively so
I just think there'll always be change
at the end of the day it seems Brad's
feathers weren't too ruffled I mean him
and Ryan seem to have a good
relationship remember Brad's cameo in
Deadpool 2. maybe the wind can't blow
but I can't see
[Music]
as for how Shania feels about the guys
well she had this to say to E.T who does
impress Shania Twain well both of them
do this is myself
you know Brad Pitt I mean he's like you
know stunning as successful as it gets
of course he's he's very impressive Ryan
Reynolds
watch I mean my fellow Canadian he can
do no wrong so of course he's the
perfect Target for that don't impress me
much the perfect Target
um and his response was priced so good
yeah it was so good oh I mean just so
good I just watch it over and over again
that response adorable lovely lovely man
and so talented
[Music]